about two weeks ago Apple refresh the 5k
iMac with new processors graphics RAM
and I called it the iMac pro killer was
I right can this I nine iMac with mega
graphics competes with a $5,000 iMac pro
to give you a spoiler yes and it's
actually faster in some ways we'll be
taking a look at photos and video
editing gaming performance connections
and more check out the description for
links to both of these machines along
with my personal recommendations let's
start out with prices if you spec these
Macs as closely as possible there's only
a $750 difference but the beauty of the
standard imax is that you can have way
more flexibility when ordering one so if
you don't need a one terabyte SSD you're
not forced to buy one you can also
upgrade the RAM yourself without voiding
your warranty which could save you up to
six hundred and eighty dollars I'll
leave links to the RAM that we use in
our easy install guide down below if
you're comparing these two you likely
need performance butter on a budget so
we think that the configuration we
purchased makes the most sense you have
an 8 core CPU with Vega 40 graphics and
a price savings of around $1,600 on the
exterior the design is practically the
same other than the space great color of
the pro which to be honest looks really
nice
you also get matching peripherals with a
full-size keyboard the displays are
identical which isn't a bad thing the 5k
resolution is still stunning and is
quite bright with great color accuracy
at the top the webcam is better on the
iMac Pro being 1080p instead of 720 and
along with that died Mac Pro has better
speakers as well moving to the back that
Mac Pro no longer has access to ram
meaning you can't easily upgrade it
yourself but because of that we have
dual fan cooling which may not make a
huge difference with the eight cores but
you definitely need that if you're gonna
buy an iMac pro with 18 cores one thing
that could make your purchasing decision
for you is the i/o die Mac Pro has
double the Thunderbolt 3 ports and 10
Gigabit Ethernet built in now not
everybody needs these ports in fact some
won't use them at all but for others
having two Thunderbolt 3 ports could be
quite limiting especially because the
only way to add a 10 Gigabit Ethernet to
the standard iMac is with a thunderbolt
adapter meaning you could be left with
just one port along with that the SD
card reader in the iMac Pro supports
faster UHS to speeds
both processors in these machines have 8
cores and 16 threads but the clock speed
on the I 9 regular iMac is higher up to
5 gigahertz instead of 4 point
- which leads us to Geekbench for cpu
test where the 2019 iMac has a 25%
higher single core score this shows how
it will perform with simple single chord
tasks so could actually feel more snappy
day to day looking at multi-core the i9
iMac scores about 8% higher showing off
its power when pushing all the pores in
Cinebench r15 which is a rendering
benchmark that pushes all the course of
their Mac's the scores are similar but
the 2019 iMac still comes out ahead
these results are impressive to me
seeing how this iMac with an unchanged
single cooling fan design is beating thy
Mac Pro but what about the graphics
clearly the Vega 56 an iMac pro is a
higher tier card than the Vega 48 in
Geekbench for the I Pro scores 20 to 25%
higher with the OpenCL and metal tests
now you shouldn't buy either one of
these machines for gaming but say you
want to have some fun after the work is
done we tested you Newton's heavens
extreme preset an iMac Pro had only
about a 5 percent higher FPS in real
world gaming that's a very small
difference and both of these can perform
quite well with higher settings under
boot camp at 1440p resolution check out
our dedicated gaming video if you want
to see what performance you can get in
real games now let's jump into photo
editing we tested using Adobe's
Lightroom classic and both machines
perform very well as they should when
you're editing importing 50 raw 42
megapixel images the standard iMac is
slightly faster generating one-to-one
previews dye Mac Pro is a few seconds
faster and exporting all 50 raw edited
photos to JPEGs took basically the same
amount of time if you edit photos this
practically no difference now let's jump
into video editing and believe it or not
the standard 5k iMac was 13% faster
overall when I averaged out all of the
tests and all the programs that I tested
if you added standard 4kh a26 for
footage thionite imac is an overall
better value especially in Premiere Pro
but if you're starting to work with
h.265 footage die Mac Pro jumps aways
ahead because of its t2 chip which the
2019 iMac doesn't have as far as editing
smoothness both are fantastic overall
the graphics card seemed to render
stabilization and effects very similarly
in the real world which is surprising
this is a very difficult topic since the
results can vary so much based on your
editing program and even the files you
work with so if you want to see which
one is faster for your use case and why
check out our full detailed video
editing comparison after this video
Mac Pro is a really nice machine I love
the color the fact that has more ports
and updated speakers it's definitely the
nicer all-in-one but it's also a very
expensive machine now the Apple went
from offering at most a four core i7 all
the way up to a five gigahertz eight
core I nine along with more powerful
graphics I feel that for most the
standard iMac provides such a great
value unless you need the extra ports
the 2099 iMac provides fantastic
performance which is actually better
overall than iMac Pro at a much lower
price and I think for most people it's
the better choice
thank you guys for watching if you want
to see more videos like this one click
the little circle above and check out
our dedicated gaming and video editing
comparisons right over here
[Music]